hey guys I'm Alex welcome back to my
apartment so last night I was hanging
out sitting on the couch watching some
Netflix might involve some Tigers and I
bought it with these strongest sweet
tooth but this time I was out of luck I
don't have anything to eat so I got a
little creative and I came up with
something that was so delicious that I
am so excited to share with all of you
this is a recipe for my brown butter
pantry cookies I have own pantry cookies
because you can literally throw anything
you have in your pantry in this what's
also really cool about this cookie is
that it doesn't use any flour at all
alright enough talking let's get cooking
alright here we are back in my kitchen
now like I said this is a totally
customizable cookie that's why I call
them pantry cookies for me I'm gonna be
using some coconut some chocolate chips
and some chopped walnuts if you don't
have these ingredients on hand don't
stress you could switch out walnuts for
pecans you could add some dried fruit
you can just totally omit the coconut
whatever works for you for the flower
we're gonna be using oats these are
whole rolled oats I'm gonna be putting
these in the blender to grind it up into
an oat flour we have two sources of
sweetness here we've got brown sugar and
maple syrup they just work really well
together if you don't have maple syrup
you can swap and hunting or you could
bump up the brown sugar lastly just some
other basic pantry items baking soda
salt butter and that's it all right time
to make the dough
I know flour can be super hard to come
by these days
so I really wanted to create a delicious
recipe so that it didn't stop you from
baking making a flower is super easy I'm
just gonna pop these rules oats into my
blender and blend
all right and just like that we've got a
flower so do you take a look it's
actually very similar to the consistency
of regular flour it's a little bit
grittier of course because we're using
oats and grinding ourselves so now that
our oat flour is done or giving a move
in on the rest of our dry ingredients so
to the oat flour I'm gonna be adding a
teaspoon of salt I'm also gonna add a
half teaspoon of baking soda and finally
a half a cup of full rolled oats I like
using full rolled oats on top of the oak
lower because it just gives that added
texture to the final cookie you want to
make sure it's fully mixed and we're
gonna set our dry ingredients aside for
now all right moving on to probably my
favorite part about this cookie the
brown butter gives this awesome
luxurious rich nuttiness to your cookie
but don't let that intimidate you it's
super easy to make melt your butter down
and get those brown bits and thank me
later it's also helpful to use a lighter
pan so that you can check the color of
the butter as it cooks but it's not
necessary I don't have a lighter pan so
this is what I'm using or maybe you're
going to want to pay close attention to
your butter because there's only a few
seconds between brown butter and Burke
butter and we don't want burnt butter in
this recipe all right 6 tablespoons of
butter going in you want to keep a close
watch of your butter once it's melted
you're gonna want to keep stirring we
just want to make sure it doesn't burn
again making brown butter takes a few
extra minutes here but it's worth it I
promise all right so now my butter has
completely melted down and I'm gonna
keep stirring you'll notice that your
butter starts to foam up that's totally
normal and then eventually you'll notice
some brown bits forming at the bottom
keep it stirring and once it's brown
we'll take it off the heat our butter is
brown it looks good smells super
delicious
all right into our brown butter I'm
gonna add 1/3 of a cup of brown sugar
fourth of a cup of maple syrup again a
super awesome flavor from the maple
syrup here one egg
and now whisk you're gonna want to mix
this up pretty well I always try to do
that having mixing well everything is
separated and then once we add in the
dry ingredients you're gonna want to
switch to more of like a full
alright the wet is mixed so now I'm
gonna start adding our dry ingredients
to the wet ingredients and again I'm
switching to a spatula to fold it all
together the dough is gonna look fairly
wet when it comes together don't worry
as the dough sits the oats will continue
to absorb some of that moisture oh it
smells so good alright and finally I'm
gonna add in the yummy stuff so again
I'm using shredded unsweetened coconut
chopped walnuts and chocolate chips you
can swap in whatever you have on hand
don't stress I'm adding a half a cup of
each of these toppings just cuz this
makes for a really nice chunky textured
cookie give it a final mix alright so
now I'm gonna let this dough hang out on
the counter at room temperature for
about ten to fifteen minutes this will
help the dough absorb some of that
moisture so that it comes together more
easily you could also pop it in the
fridge but that will result in like a
fluffier cookie and I like my cookies a
little bit flatter and chillier I also
should mention that I have my oven
preheating to 350 degrees alright see
you soon our dough has been hanging out
for about 15 minutes
if you give it a little mix you'll
notice that it's a lot thicker than it
was originally so that's a really
important step so I just use about a
spoonful of dough then I transfer it
into my hand
and roll it into a ball and then just
pop it on the sheet the cookies don't
spread out too much so you don't have to
worry about them being too close but I
still leave like an inch apart the dough
is a little bit sticky so your hands
will probably get a little messy but it
just adds to the fun this is definitely
an activity you can do with kids working
for the cookies I'm sure they won't mind
last one for this tray beautiful no not
saying I've tried this dough because
there is egg in there but it's really
good I'm gonna use a spoon it to flatten
these cookies out this will help you get
the perfect cookie shape if your spoon
sticks too much too
the dough you can oil the back of it so
that it comes off nice and easy and I
just try to go around with my finger and
kind of reshape them just to make sure
they're nice and round finally and this
is totally optional I'm gonna add a
little bit of flaky salt on the top of
each one I really like flaky salt on
cookies just adds a little like
something some alright and now we bake
so I'm gonna make these at 350 degrees
for about seven minutes they cook pretty
quickly which is the plus just check
them to make sure they don't burn
alright our timer just went off I'm
gonna check on the cookies those are
looking so good
so these cookies are a little bit
fragile because we're using oak flour so
I'm gonna let them cool a bit on the pan
itself because if I try to transfer them
now they'll probably break then I'll
transfer them to a plate to cool even
more and then we've got our cookies and
there you have it our brown butter
pantry cookies are done they smell so
good
I cannot wait to try it mmm these are so
good they've got the perfect balance of
salty to sweet they've got so much
texture from all the stuff we put in
there the caramelized sweetness from the
brown sugar and the maple syrup goes so
well with that brown butter and the
walnuts mmm
definitely a cookie that will satisfy
the sweet tooth my sweet tooth
specifically all right well I hope you
enjoyed this video if you make these
cookies please tag me I'd love to see it
and remember stay home wash your hands
and eat a cookie oh yes
[Music]